[Applaudissements]
atmosphère d'émeutes à beyrouth cette
nuit plusieurs centaines de manifestants
ont défié les forces de l'ordre dans les
rues de la capitale
objectif dénoncer la situation
économique catastrophique du pays et la
corruption des dirigeants source
d'inquiétude pour le gouvernement la
livre libanaise a frôlé le seuil des
5000 livres pour un dollar dans les
bureaux de change
un énième coup dur pour l'économie du
pays et sa population
officiellement à d'excès sur le dollar
depuis 1997 au taux fixe de 1507 livre
pour un dollar la monnaie libanaise est
en chute libre depuis octobre 2019
de nombreux habitants sont excédés de la
situation un dollar américain vaut 7000
livres libanaises pourquoi est ce que
les gens sont encore chez eux
tous les magasins sont fermés et les
gens aux fins vous manifestiez pour vos
fêtes et vos confession mais maintenant
pour votre pays vous êtes toujours acier
à la maison donc qu'est-ce que vous
attendez le gouvernement et les partis
politiques ne sont pas capables et ne
veulent pas sauver le pays de la crise
actuelle
ils veulent le volet ils ne se soucient
pas du pays aujourd'hui nous sommes dans
les rues et cela fait presque six mois
mais maintenant c'est insupportable
parce que la situation économique est un
désastre et que personne ne fait rien
plusieurs feux se sont déclarés à
beyrouth près de la place des martyrs
des centaines de protestataires en
scooter ont parcouru les rues de la
capitale afin de dénoncer riad salamé
gouverneur de la banque centrale ainsi
que le gouvernement du premier ministre
hassan diab des affrontements ont opposé
manifestants et forces de l'ordre ces
dernières ont fait usage de gaz
lacrymogènes afin de disperser la foule
des tensions aussi présente à tripoli
dans le nord du pays où des
protestataires ont tenté d'investir la
branche locale de la banque centrale
des événements qui ont fait au moins
huit blessées dans la cité côtière
en réponse à ces événements le premier
ministre hassan diab a annulé l'ensemble
des réunions prévues ce vendredi pour
convoquer d'urgence le conseil des
ministres afin de trouver des solutions
à la crise financière
en effet le pays traverse sa crise
économique la plus grave depuis la fin
de la guerre civile en 1990 des
négociations vital entre le gouvernement
libanais et le fonds monétaire
international sont en cours sur une aide
qui permettrait au pays d'enrayer
l'effondrement de son économie
une possible bouée de sauvetage pour un
état à la dérive